to lie it you were a lock down Governor
did you catch that California governor
Gavin Nome says Florida Governor Ron de
santis supported covid lockdowns yes
Florida closed many public and private
spaces in March 2020 but Gavin Nome
isn't one to talk the governor called
himself a zoom parent while his kids
attended in-person learning at their
private school he ordered all beaches
and parks in Orange County to close he
denied kids the freedom to use a
playground while places like malls
remained open and who can forget his
French Laundry dinner party after he
shut down restaurants all across his
State gin Newsome is trying to Gaslight
voters into forgetting his atrocious
pandemic record but it won't work and
here's the thing the fact that a
democratic politician is now throwing
around the phrase lockdown Governor as a
criticism shows that the debate around
covid is over those of us who favored
freedom and personal responsibility over
the heavy hand of government yeah we won